i'm hoping that they step in and
give archie a right to live i think that
he deserves that we've got two other
countries have come forward and um
they've offered archie treatment
if this country can't treat him or
they're not willing to treat him where
is the harm in allowing him to go to
another country you know we need to
advance
like medical technology i think or like
medicines and what better way to allow
archie to go to see if this can actually
be done
they said that
they won't withdraw whilst is being
considered
sorry
[Music]
but we we have actually asked obviously
we've put into place the worst case
scenario and asked for archie to
um go to a hospice and this hospital
rootedly said no
so
the courts are going on and really
focusing in on the word dignity what is
dignified in dying in a busy hospital
room full of noise with the door open
people coming in and out continuously
when archie could be in a very peaceful
garden with squirrels and wildlife
running around to have his life support
withdrawn now
where
if they really want to focus on this
world dignity then i think that that
option seriously needs to be also looked
at but obviously that is worst case
scenarios there as i've said there are
other countries that want to take
archery and they want to treat him
[Music]
i'm i'm running on empty yesterday was a
very down day for me and
people that know me know i won't stay
down for long especially when it comes
to fighting my son's life so today i'm
back up again and i'm fighting i
promised arch the same with his dad that
we will fight till the bitter end and
that's exactly what we're going to do
we're going to fight for the right for
my son to live
other countries are so supportive
with regards to treatment that they want
to take um archie they can offer him
this treatment they've got high success
rates
and i personally don't see the harm if
they can offer the slightest bit of hope
god forbid that hope goes wrong it will
move back forward with and more advanced
in obviously medical
like medical advance you know it's uh
why not give him that chance
why is it so cut and shut he has to die
in this country because this country
don't want to treat him no more there's
other countries that want to treat him
and i think that he should be allowed to
go
tokyo italy
[Music]
um he's good he's had a stable night
again he's good he's good
i think everyone that's followed me on
my facebook page love actually i put
videos up i've put pictures up daily i
put his stats up daily
he is very very different to what the
hospital
clinicians have put forward to the cult
he's stable and he's he's been stable
the whole time we're on day 117 i think
it is now
because at the minute i i haven't inside
i'm broke i'm not going to lie i'm broke
and at some point i am going to need
serious therapy but i haven't got time
to think about me at the minute this is
a serious fight for my son's life and
i'm up against a bigger system
and
a trust i haven't got time to break down
at the moment
it's
it's really hard it's
i feel for the nurses because it is
causing a lot of attention it's said in
court that
our nurses are so distressed they're
about to take time off no the nurses
have actually been on holidays i can i
can give you a list of what nurses
obviously not mentioning names what
holidays they've been they've all come
back with their nice hands so again
total misleading to what's been put
across to the colts but
the nurses that work with archie you
know the relationship's good with us and
actually they're there to do their job
and they're doing an amazing job the
clinicians not so good and there is one
clinician that
i suppose i am on good terms with but
with regards to anything else now it's
not good it's totally broken down